[Musique]
elle
où
kalou
impossible pour un bébé de se souvenir
de son premier livre des premières pages
des expériences pourtant essentielle au
développement de l'enfant depuis huit
ans des mamans et leurs enfants
participent à cette initiative du
département en collaboration avec l'adac
au est quasiment tous les jours il ya
toujours un livre qui traîne avec lequel
il peut admirer les images poser des
questions ici malgré qu'ils parlent pas
mais ils nous posent des questions il
nous fait comprendre et on lui explique
les choses
il appréhende aussi l'objet quoi parce
que c'est vrai que maintenant avec la
société où on a beaucoup les smartphones
les écrans et s'est rassis commence très
tôt à appréhender le papier à pouvoir
toucher manipuler l'objet
ça commence aussi à leur donner envie de
lire plus tard à grabels au bmi qui vous
apporteront conseils sur la parentalité
l'éducation de vos marmaille à tous les
âges la collectivité accompagne le
développement de nos enfants est l'un
des objectifs majeurs de cette opération
est d'infléchir le chiffre des cent
seize mille personnes en situation
d'illettrisme à la réunion sans compter
la partie de notre jeunesse en
difficulté avec la lecture ces moments
magiques j'ai envie de dire et c'est un
moment aussi de dire aux parents vous
n'êtes pas seuls le département est à
vos côtés on veut vous accompagner
aujourd'hui l'éducation commence déjà
dans nos familles dans chaque famille
respective et l'éducation amène aussi à
un savoir lire écrire c'est la lecture
dès le plus jeune âge
avec un spectacle et des ateliers
l'espace régler est redevenue une cour
de récréation
la hausse qui l'aimé beaucoup c'est que
en fait une histoire va être partagée
c'est donc j'espère de l'émotion de la
curiosité
julie dans un univers aussi où il
retrouve les siens ou donc quelque chose
de l'ordre de la douceur
et du suspense puisque on va aller
jusqu'au bout cette histoire est à se
demander bâtiment retrouver sa chanson
et à voir le regard des enfants sur
l'auteur du livre certains ont ouvert
aujourd'hui les portes du monde
merveilleux de la lecture
[Musique]